i want to go back to this whole superman
idea that you have right because um
because i think it's very interesting
that um
i think it's interesting this superman
so you're saying right what you said
before
is that there has to be when do you have
a masculine woman yeah
there has to be
a type of
superman yeah to put her in her feminine
is what you're trying to say
so like i said
men
do not want to battle with women
that are we battle with men like i was
saying we back we're men we battle with
men
we shouldn't be battling with women
someone you know i'm saying hang on hang
on wait so we shouldn't be battling with
women and the fact that a man would want
to take on a battle
from a woman
says to me that he's not ready to take
on a battle from a man
and the reason why it says that is
because the real battle as men is with
men
you don't battle women if a woman is
combative and she's masculine leave her
to the side because that's not what the
hang on because that's not the battle
that men need to be taken on men take on
battles from other
women
sorry other men sorry they don't take on
battles from women and if a man thinks
oh you know what i'm going to battle
this woman because she's too masculine
and i'm going to dominate her no men
wanna bro i'm just saying
the battle for men
is amongst other men but this is the
thing that i was
saying while i was in my plane is that
isn't the fact of the battle it's the
fact that in the even because let's be
honest as a female it is not her natural
to be of in her masculine energies is
that something that we can agree on well
it's natural
she said she just said she's basically
said that she is because of her because
of her upbringing right right but not
from when she was born that's not how
she was from what it would have been her
if there was none of that came right she
is a girl she is a girl she is a girl
and that is that is the fact yeah she's
a woman she is not naturally in her
masculine energies because she's a girl
she's naturally in a feminine energy
right what no
okay no no she's already said she's
naturally in her masculine no no but i'm
saying i'm saying i'm not saying what
she is but i'm saying you're saying
nature aesthetically
she's a woman yeah i get you yeah so
the things that she's still as a as a as
a female attracted to men as well the
things that she's attracted to are still
the same things that other women are
attracted to 100 percent yeah so still
as may whatever the level of that level
still being
as my and that's what i was going to say
to you i'm not trying to battle the
difference between the supermarket is a
battle she will know from the sense from
the time same way another woman will
know that there's i'm not going to
battle with she will know when it is
superman yeah i'm not battling it
doesn't matter
you might say that to fight that you
have to battle and that's because maybe
you feel like you for the only way for
you to actually challenge this is the
battle i know me personally i'm not
battling that but still beth will
conform
i'm saying that men
if you're what you're saying is you got
too much time on your hands for me yeah
because hang away
wait wait wait wait wait narrative
wait wait wait the reason why is because
my battle
as soon as i step out the door
not even just
me being a man my battle is as soon as i
step out the door i got a lot of things
to battle as a man do you know what i'm
saying and you do too
and even being a black man
you have a lot of things to battle when
you step out that door of course trust
me my brother yeah when you get back in
the house and the door that you step out
of the one thing you don't want
is after battling outside to have a
battle inside what is my cause i'm
telling you bro it will take its toll on
you as a man you do not need a woman
inside the house to be battling with
when you've just battled the whole world
outside because your house
is not always trying to become no but
the thing is no but a woman a woman hang
on but a woman in her feminine side a
woman in her masculine it's easier to
handle but still that's a woman in a
feminist easter handle oh yeah the woman
and that's feminine is female right
courtroom but listen that expected
ground
that you you say you're going home to
i'm saying that the aura the level of
super that you have to be is still on
it's on the same it's on the same
spectrum as a super feminine woman yeah
a man that battles the rest of the world
we don't need super feminine family
women not super family i'm just talking
about the spectrums right whatever
spectrum that you're on
uh the the more feminine you are you
don't have to battle it means you have
to battle less right still so the more
masculine you are technically right
still means no matter what level her
masculinity is on still if it is
dominant enough it will still not be a
battle bro
it's too much work it's too much work
only if it's not who you are it's only
work but you see me my all right why is
your work going because you got it
i'm saying it's work for you but my
whole point
what he's trying to say is like it's not
going to be work because she wouldn't be
that energy around him
she's neutralizing it
she would have a different energy with
the right person that's what he's trying
to say so he's saying it's not going to
be he's not going to try and battle
where he's going to be masculine against
that's not what he's going to try and do
she's going to naturally just like it's
a film where you just naturally bring it
down and it's not a thing where i'm
going to now go back he's not going to
be about at home that's what he's trying
to say i don't understand that
so you think so you see you see um
so you see
women that are feminine that don't
battle yeah yeah or masculine women that
put up a little bit of a battle or
whatever battle what what do you think
men are looking for generally
i mean every men's um they're what
they're looking for their preference is
different it just depends on what you
feel like dealing with or what you feel
like that's why you don't understand so
i got a question
that's serious that's why you don't
understand man i got a question what do
you think men prefer though what do you
think we prefer
majority of men prefer what you're
saying i hate where you're coming from
okay then why don't you why why don't we
why don't you give us what majority men
want though
come on
you're gonna have to fall for someone
you're not gonna be single for your life
so you could you're gonna look for the
feminine you are but if you're gonna if
you're not gonna find a feminine guess
what you're gonna have to find someone
here let me let me let me let me land as
well let me tell you something i'll
understand that you want someone i might
as well go with i'm not homosexual i
might as well go over a man okay i guess
if i'm gonna bathe a masculine woman
there's no way
no
that's a representation
hold on hang on hold on hold on hold on
speak what i'm trying to say is yeah men
like i said the general ash gets it and
i think i even think you get it do you
know what i'm saying i think you
actually you do you actually get it hang
away
i know you men and even
are you the superman though are you that
guy wait wait wait let's calm it down
calm it down pop it down calm down calm
down calm it down calm it down
i think men
have been
have been coming wait well what hang on
hang on hang away wait hold on wait wait
i think men
have become so used to yeah
masculine women yeah
that now
they are
accommodating
the traits of masculine women
what it is is that the women of this
generation hang on guys behind the
camera hang on
the women of this generation have become
so masculine yeah for so long that men
have started to accommodate
mass masculine women and like i said at
the end of the day when all is said and
done and when the dust settles and the
smoke clears
masculine women in general respect
masculine men however they need to
understand that if they are in their
masculine
they're not going to attract
the masculine men because like like like
ash said masculine and masculine don't
attract unless you're a homosexual right
that's that's the bottom line the
masculine masculine attract unless
you're a homosexual clearly i'm not that
masculine then
clearly i'm not a masculine attractor
you said yourself
away with it you know what let me know
you said yourself in the relationship
that you had previous
that you felt like the man
not the man
you felt like the more masculine before
you left right so hang on so the man you
got with was a feminine man
was a feminine man no right so yes and
we were speaking about this yesterday
masculine women tend to attract feminine
men they tend to go with feminine men
because there are because masculine and
feminine attract one another i
understand you know what is a hundred
percent understand where you're coming
from
you know what yeah here it comes one
thing cool let me ask you something
about earlier this month's [ __ ] so
let me ask you a question do you think
that i get
into well you don't know i don't know
your life do you think that
would you assume
that i get into a lot of confrontations
with men
um
i would say that if a man did get into a
confrontation with you i would say that
it would be more of a battle than it
would be with a feminine woman so do you
think i'm not saying that you get into a
lot of them because i wouldn't know so
are you married
no
do you have a girl
not at this moment
why not because i was in a 10-year
relationship i recently broke up with my
through a 10-year relationship
all right cool
can i ask you why it ended
what's that still the conversation
because it might play into toxic
masculinity or femininity there was
there was nothing to do with toxic
masculinity or toxic feminine there's a
reason why it broke up cool
so
cool so i'm interested in why when when
it came to my
beth this is this is where this
statement is yeah this is where it
really lands today because
we're talking about
first we we had to talk we had to
take out whoever is beneath
the the level of
men that um females are attracted to
right we're talking about
the level of men that that their
attracted to you that percentage that
they they didn't want to say the numbers
in it but it was you know we do the
numbers that we're talking about we know
we know what type of men they're talking
about anyway
the five eight no no they ain't talking
about superman superman unfortunately
supermen are on a another level because
listen because you're basically saying
that average level that you're talking
about may not be able to handle some of
my blackberry which is something that i
do agree with right however if all men
were then
supermen right if you are able to handle
beth basically the same woman that
you're also able to handle and maybe not
be able to have the time
the person you don't want to handle you
might not want to handle a level like
beth
a superman though can handle someone
like beth and then also handle someone
like
miss i don't know your name miss i don't
know your name
no matter what whatever level if let's
if we were to say that beth is at the
top level of masculinity right no matter
every level beneath though a superman
however not every man is a superman
though that's what the problem that's
what it is do you understand that even
saying that a woman is at a top level of
masculinity is not attractive
right like do you even understand that
that is not